barbara's in springfield missouri hey
barbara your question for anthony o'neil
and me
hello thank you for taking my call sure
i'm
61 years old and i'm thinking about
retiring and i'm trying to figure out
if i have enough money i'm kind of
scared i told my boss
this would be my last year of driving so
i'm debt-free i've been debt-free since
probably 2009.
and i am
i have plenty of money in the bank but
you don't know how long you're going to
live
so my question is i have an opportunity
to buy
like five years of employment from where
i work now i'm a school bus driver
and that would increase my monthly
benefit
from 248 dollars a month to 428 dollars
a month but it'll take
10 years to recover that yeah
that is not a good rate of return
and so you're better off to invest the
money how much money do you have
in the bank you said um
i have 624 000.
okay good it's a lot better than uh
248 dollars a month huh absolutely yeah
okay and how is that 624 000 invested
okay i've got thrift savings plan i've
got savings bonds
state farm life state farm mutual funds
and state farm cds 36 000 of that is in
two separate
regular savings accounts okay
all right very good well here's the
great news
you got 624 000 yeah
that's great news i don't know i don't
know how to go about
how do you know you don't know how long
you're going to live well
it's helpful to do the calculation if
you know how long you're going to live
but most of us don't have that part of
the calculations
what i do um i mean you and i are the
same age i'm 60
okay what would i do if i woke up in
your shoes
and suddenly knew what i know
okay i would sit down with a smartvestor
pro like i was just talking about
and begin to learn so your
job is not to become a financial
genius your job is to understand the
basics
of investing okay
okay and good mutual funds you said you
had some state farm mutual funds they
may or may not be performing well i
don't know anything about them off the
top of my head
but your job is to say i've got this 624
how can i
best position it with some
help and some people guiding and
teaching me
but them not doing it for you no one's
making your decision for you you
you're the one with the money right yes
and so you sit down the reason we
endorse these smartvestor pros is they
have the heart
of a teacher based on what you told me
i think you'll end up probably moving
over time most of your
investments because i think most of them
can do better than they're doing now
okay and let's just pretend that you
made
let's just round numbers ten percent on
your money
that'd be sixty thousand a year right
yeah five thousand dollars a month
and i bet you can make it on that oh
easy yeah and so if you made
half that and or maybe you made that and
you let some of it stay in there and
grow
and you didn't take it all out and you
say i'm gonna live on three thousand
dollars a month and everything above
that that it makes i'm gonna let it grow
okay okay as long as you're not
hitting the actual goose that's laying
the eggs
it lasts forever yeah mathematically
meaning if you don't get into the 624
if you only take off what it creates and
live on that
it'll create something every stinking
year right
i understand yeah so you're going to be
fine you've done
very very well yeah what's your home
worth
my home well i have 160 acre farm and i
wouldn't take less than 400
000 for it and so you're what we call a
millionaire bus driver
[Laughter]
how did you do that well i had a real
good job for a few years
and i've always my parents taught me
this when i was young
not to overspend and no matter what kind
of money i made
i always lived as if i were on minimum
wage
and i am i have to admit though
um 200 000 of this is
life insurance from my late husband and
my mother gave me 70
000 before she passed away so not all
this is
27 of your million dollar net worth came
from someone else and the rest of it you
did
yeah i'm so proud of you very very well
done thank you so here's the thing my
husband and i
did yeah here's what i would do um state
farm
might be okay for car insurance they're
not great for investments
okay but you can decide that on your own
not because i said it
right and what you do is you sit down
and learn about some mutual funds
my personal mutual funds and what we
recommend anthony
four types right yes sir yes sir growth
oh growth and income was an underhand
pitch you were supposed to hit it but
i'll take it for you
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international
growth oh yeah and if you spread it
across those four
and you buy mutual funds that have long
track records 10 years or more
then you can say okay over the last 30
years had i been invested in these i
would have made x
and as long as i live on something less
than x
the goose will continue to lay the eggs
does that make sense
it does and i think you can do that what
do you live on now
i um about 1200 a month
okay so if we if we gave you a raise of
100
and your 624 was still growing that
would be pretty nice situation for
retirement
it would be very nice not counting the
fact you get 248 on top of that
right yeah don't buy the retirement sit
down with somebody and let's get your
money invested well
you have done so well barbara so well
some millionaire bus driver
millionaire bus driver dave sorry about
that i was waving at the kids leaving
but uh
get to tell you yeah you're distracted
with the audience
um but the uh um
you know what's the point i i told my
boss this year
yeah i don't think i'm gonna drive
anymore right
right i'm a millionaire
self-made at that 27 other than that is
good
but now dave let me ask you this
question a learning thing for me uh from
you
having someone of that age in your age
bracket saying they're coming close to
retirement careful
careful i mean i'm not i'm not calling
you old careful i'm calling you a young
man people like you
but dave would you recommend her sell
the house if she could get four hundred
thousand dollars for it no
okay why wouldn't you not recommend that
but number one she said she absolutely
loves the place yes
168 acres yeah that's a lot that's sweet
yeah
yeah yeah unless it's given her problems
okay um
in some way financially or physically or
whatever okay it may come a point you
don't want to maintain it right
but uh but right now sounds like a nice
place to me yeah
yeah have a cup of coffee on that back
porch baby